this is a Fox News Alert on Bret bear in
Washington the Justice Department
Inspector General says then FBI director
James Comey
was insubordinate during the Hillary
Clinton email investigation the report
also reveals a text message in which one
investigator tells an FBI lawyer that
they will stop Donald Trump from being
elected but the report does not directly
attribute political motives to those
actions just moments ago the current
director of the FBI promised that people
will be held accountable but insisted
noting that were in the report impugns
the integrity of the bureau as a whole
we have extensive coverage tonight
including reaction from two chairman
trey Gowdy and Bob Goodlatte but we
begin with chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge at the
Justice Department tonight
lots of digests good evening Catherine
well thank you Bret this 500-page report
was 17 months in the making
it addresses allegations of political
bias and it found that Attorney General
Loretta Lynch showed bad judgment an FBI
director James Comey was insubordinate
no charges are appropriate in this case
when FBI director James Comey gave his
July 2016 public statement the Inspector
General found Comey went outside the
chain of command when he intentionally
kept his boss attorney general Loretta
Lynch and her deputy Sally Yates in the
dark quote we found that it was
extraordinary and insubordinate for
Comey to do so the report set and we
found none of his reasons to be a
persuasive basis for deviating from
well-established department policies in
a tweet Comey responded I respect the
DOJ IG office which is why I urge them
to do this review the conclusions are
reasonable even though I disagree with
some people of good faith can see an
unprecedented situation differently on
text messages between FBI agent Peters
struck an FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
Inspector General Michael Horowitz found
no documentary or testimonial evidence
of political bias that impacted
investigative decisions prior to commis
July 2016 event in a recent Fox
interview Comey said politics played no
roles I was deeply disappointed in them
but I never saw any bias any reflection
of any kind of animus towards anybody
including me
part of an ongoing forensic review a
text message recovered last month
suggests truck may have acted for
political reasons much later than
initially believed in August 2016 page
wrote Trump's not ever going to become
president right right struck replied no
no he won't we'll stop it in late
September investigators found tens of
thousands of Clinton emails on a laptop
computer shared by Clinton aide Huma
Abedin and her husband Anthony Weiner as
part of a separate investigation the
Inspector General said struck dragged
his feet and no action was taken until
two weeks before the election when Comey
reopened the email case quote under
these circumstances we did not have
confidence that Struck's decision to
prioritize the Russia investigation over
the Weiner laptop was free from bias but
Struck's attorneys dispute that saying
the facts contained in the report lead
to the conclusion the delays were caused
by miscommunications on the June 2016
Arizona tarmac meeting between Attorney
General Loretta Lynch and Bill Clinton
the report concluded Lynch showed bad
judgment when she took the meeting and
failed to recognize the appearance
problem created by former President
Clinton's visit and to take action to
cut the visits short was an error in
judgment on whether the Clinton emails
containing classified information were
hacked the Inspector General uncovered
an FBI report that was conducted after
the election he concluded quote
classified information was compromised
by unauthorized individuals to include
foreign governments or intelligence
services via cyber intrusion from
accounts linked to Clinton's server
within the last hour we heard from FBI
director Christopher Rea who said he
accepts the findings of the Inspector
General he acknowledged that mistakes
were made and he said there would be
consequences the report does identify
errors of judgment violations of or even
disregard for policy and decisions that
at the very least with the benefit of
hindsight were not the best choices
we've already started taking the
necessary steps to address those issues
first we're gonna hold employees
accountable also director Rea emphasized
that this was a single investigation and
a handful employees were involved he
also emphasized that this is not in any
way in his opinion impune the overall
integrity of the FBI and its workforce
Brett Catherine great job reporting
thank you